>> That was correct, David. Now this particular problem might look very simple.
Because for you and me as humans, going from this state to this state is almost
trivial. But notice how many different questions arose in trying to analyze
this problem. Clearly, you and I as humans must be addressing these issues.
This kind of A.I anaylsis makes explicit what is usually tacit when humans solve
this problem. And that is one of the powers of A.I.. Indeed we have left a lot
of questions unanswered. But each unanswered question then requires an answer.
Now we know that if you must develop methods that somehow will help to
address those questions. Like genetic [x] tests and like [x] dialysis.
Problem reduction is a universal method. It is applicable very large class of
problems. Once again, problem reduction does not provide guarantee of successes.